these ladies over here
are trying to recall my husband from the
school board
and i saw a woman in there that really
doesn't like us
and i
kind of wonder
maybe she did something
[Music]
hi i'd like to report a potential drunk
driver i'm a little
uh worried for her kid we're at safeway
getting signatures and um she was
talking to the people and just like
slurring her words and her eyes
were curling around she's got her
daughter with her and i'd hate to see
her get in an accident hello can you
hear me can you hear me
yep you broke up a little bit where
exactly are they located
we're in the safeway parking lot and
they're loading their car now and i'm
just worried she's intoxicated with her
daughter
okay and what makes you believe that
there's that she's intoxicated
um she came up to our two volunteers and
started repeating herself slur in her
words her eyes she were twitching back
and forth and they're like i think she's
really drunk
and uh she wasn't harassing them like
we've gotten but she was just combative
a little bit and then when i checked out
she couldn't figure out how to
self-check out she like couldn't hit the
buttons right
um so i just i didn't want to there to
be an accident and a little girl in a
car and not at least call just to make
sure okay what type of vehicle is that
she is in a chevy hold on
is what the female look like is she
white brunette
yeah she's caucasian brunette
probably late 40s
with a girl that looks under 10.
okay
you have a driver's license on you by
any chance
so
what we got going on tonight
excuse me what do we have going on
tonight
what do we have going on tonight i'm
grocery shopping for my family okay okay
so another question for you have we had
anything to drink tonight me yes okay
okay do you have a
child with you no
okay
said that you had a small kid with you
a caller a caller said that you had a
smoker yes ma'am okay do do we eat
i i mean i can
yeah you got groceries in the back and
i've got a car seat okay my kids are
home with my husband right now gotcha
you wouldn't by any chance have any idea
on you just saying that i'm in contact
with you for sure
a caller yeah
saying that i'd had something to drink
yeah and then you had a small child with
you
okay yeah that's interesting well is
there
yeah okay what's going on possibly a
reason for that okay um
these ladies over here
are trying to recall my husband from the
school board
and i saw a woman in there that really
doesn't like us
and i
kind of wonder
maybe she did something
gotcha okay i don't even drink
so okay i'm happy to show you my id
and whatever else you need
we'll come to the moon do we have uh
rp's name
might hit you your car
so it sounds a little bit like that
might be abuse of the process a little
bit
concerning
i'll have a chat with that person too
yeah i'd like to know what they actually
observed step back a little is she the
one standing at the door right now
behind us move out of his way real
quick oh she must have gone back inside
she had black video yeah yeah
looks like asian possibly
yeah
shorts can you hear us
she she has gotten up in public and said
horrible things about my family
that's recorded okay um
she she has issues with me so you
wouldn't know her name by any chance
would you sam peck
is that
yeah yeah she's right there
here you go
where's she
i think i just started walking
walking around
two living
well we haven't had anything to drink
tonight or anything like that i'm not
getting any odors from you or anything
i'm chewing down i've got ice cubes
i don't drink no i'm getting groceries
from my kids
uh like i said there's some folks over
there trying to recall my husband from
the school board
and the woman who i think probably
called
not a fan of my families so
i would suspect that's what's going on
did you have someone help you during
checkout yes was it her
no
no
no i had a uh
i had an assistant manager help me
he had what a coupon issue
[Music]
no coupon issue so
okay
all right well anything you guys need to
do
would come to eleven can i get last
three
would they say i was drunk
two little coffee seriously
yep
i just want to talk to you and i mean
even just talking with you and stuff
like that you're not slurring your words
or any statements that uh
the reporting party had claimed i'm not
getting any of that
sorry for wasting your time no it's all
right you guys are just doing your job
yes ma'am i'm sorry that you guys had
your time wasted because i think this is
probably the first yeah we can uh we'll
make it worth our time that's false
reporting it is false reporting yeah so
i take that seriously too much
yes ma'am yes ma'am yep nope uh sorry to
waste your time and hopefully i'm not
appreciative uh yeah i'm blocking you so
let me back up real quick and i'll let
you
move my car and then we're gonna go go
speak with rp
sounds like false reporting targeting
i don't know if you explain it to me
one one shy of